Republican Jeff Flake of Arizona served
in the Senate from 2013 until last year
in September he wrote in The Washington
Post my fellow Republicans it is time to
risk your careers in favor of your
principles whether you believe the
president deserves impeachment you know
he does not deserve re-election Jeff
Flake is a CBS News contributor and he
joins us with his insight on the Senate
so quite not bad there you know people
who voted for these Republicans in
Senate wouldn't when they say look we
support the President and we voted for
you we want you to support the president
also isn't it fine and dandy from a
voter perspective for them to toe the
party line no it's not we have
separation of powers and the Congress
needs to stand up for its principles and
individual members do as well that
doesn't mean that they won't agree with
the president often if you're Republican
you typically agree with the Republican
president more often but not all the
time and not to the extent particularly
that the House Republicans did to say
that the president did nothing wrong
here so I have to go back and forth the
the president the Trump administration
is saying they do not want witnesses the
Democrats do want witnesses and they're
gonna need four Republican votes to get
them looks like they might have three
right from your conversations behind the
scenes from your knowledge or the way
the Senate works and your former
colleagues will that fourth vote appear
well certainly not with the motion that
Chuck Schumer is likely to make tomorrow
he won't get any Republican votes for
that the time when witnesses may be
called as after the president makes his
case and the house impeachment managers
do so down the road then susan collins
mitt romney and and also lisa murkowski
have said that they are open to
witnesses but they still need one what
do you learn more there are other
moderate Republicans who are vulnerable
in this fall's election do you think
there are others who I mean how
difficult is that decision to make
that's a tough one for them certainly
they don't want to draw the president's
ire they've still have to win a primary
which is coming up but they have to win
a general election after that and to win
a general election in a state like
Arizona or Colorado or Maine is is
difficult unless you have said hey we're
here this evidence and we're going to
consider it like a senator should and I
think that they know that you've said
recently fellow Republicans there's
still time to save your souls you've
also said politics can make a silent
when we speak when we should speak
silence can equal complicity do you
think senator that you should have
spoken up more do you regret that you
didn't speak up more n why is it so
difficult for Republicans to speak up
against this president when they don't
believe what he's doing
tell us why that's so hard well it's
difficult because they want to keep
their jobs and the president is
extremely popular among Republican
primary voters you know that is a subset
of a subset of a subset but there they
are those who decide who represents the
party in the general election you said
the president if the president isn't the
only one on trial so we're your
Republican colleagues they are in a
sense because this president won't be
there forever he'll either be gone this
time next year or four years from now
then what happens to the Republican
Party and my fear is people out there
know that even if this is not an
impeachable offense that the president
did something wrong and for Republicans
to maintain that he didn't is just wrong
and and this has long-term ramifications
for the party if we act as if we are
just devoted to the president no matter
what kind of this cult of personality
that we've seen we certainly saw it in
the house do you wish you had spoken up
more but it seems like if you do speak
up I decide when you look back over it
I'm curious oh yeah you always look back
and say I could have done this different
for that but I did speak up and I
decided that you know I would have to
condone behavior I couldn't condone or
accept positions that I couldn't accept
if I wanted to win reelection that's why
I didn't run how do you think Mitch
McConnell the majority leader is
handling this so far in the Senate you
know I think the the fact that he they
will have a vote on witnesses after the
president and the house presents their
case that speaks well for the president
that there are I'm sorry for Mitch
McConnell that they're doing it like
they did the Clinton hearings I wouldn't
have said as he did that he will
coordinate every move with a White House
that was speaking to a conservative
group and that just says to people
he's not gonna be fair in it sound like
impartial justice no alright Jeff Flake
thank you so much for being with us